hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an episode called the hounds of
baskerville from the mystery crime show
sherlock spoilers ahead watch out and
take care
at the beginning of the episode we see a
little boy running up a hill through the
woods
he looks frantic and scared an old lady
stops the kid and asks if he is okay
the boy doesn't say anything but yells
in fear the child's name is henry knight
cut to 20 years later henry has grown up
into an adult
he stands in the same woods in dartmoor
it turns out that 20 years ago he has
seen his father got killed by a gigantic
hound the incident has traumatized henry
for life
somewhere else in london a detective
named sherlock holmes and his partner
john watson are in their apartment
sherlock comes in with a weapon and
blood all over him he has just solved
another case
sherlock is experiencing withdrawal he
has to solve cases to keep him from
smoking he throws stuff around the
apartment looking for his secret stash
of cigarettes and yelling at john to
find a case just then their doorbell
rings
in comes henry he wants sherlock to
investigate the case of his father's
death he and his father used to go for
walks to moore the woods has a place
called doer's hollow
that day a massive animal had caught
henry's father it dragged and killed him
in front of henry
he brings a news report on baskerville a
chemical and biological weapons research
center in dartmoor he's convinced that a
monster brood in the baskerville lab
killed his father
however sherlock believes that henry has
just created a story to cope with his
trauma so he dismisses him
but just then henry tells him that after
years of trauma yesterday henry has
visited the hollow where the killing
occurred and found gigantic paw prints
of a hound
the fact that henry called it a hound
instead of a dog spiked sherlock's
interest
so he and john leave for dartmouth the
following morning the two check into a
hotel and on their way see a tour guide
boasting about the hound to a group of
tourists the hound had become a local
legend and helped to grow the place's
tourism
meanwhile henry is at his therapist
louise mortimer's home
this time during this session he reveals
to her that he sees the words liberty
and n in relation to the night his
father was killed
while checking into the hotel john sees
a receipt of a large amount of meat
supplied to the hotel
thinking it is unusual he takes the bill
with him the two then talk to the tour
guide who tells them that he has seen
the hound too
he believes that the ministry of defense
research base called the baskerville
created the hound as a defense mechanism
during the war
ever since the hound has been running
around in dartmoor killing people the
two then visit baskerville they use
sherlock's brother mycroft's security
pass to get access into the building
however the establishment is highly
protected so they have only about 20
minutes before they get caught
one of the guards there offers the two a
full tour of the place
they meet a lab doctor named dr bob
franklin while touring they walk around
the labs but do not find any useful
information about the hound before
mycroft's card causes a security alert
the major is about to run an identity
check on them when suddenly dr franklin
claims to know him and backs up
sherlock's ruse
turns out franklin is a fan of
sherlock's work and he knows henry and
knew that they came to help him
franklin says he was a friend of henry's
father and is concerned for henry's
well-being
the duo then visits henry's home in
dartmoor henry offers them some tea and
tells them of the words that he keeps
seeing in his dreams liberty and in
sherlock's next plan is to visit the
doers hollow at night and investigate
the presence of the hound
the three make their way to the place in
the evening that day
as they walk john hears a noise coming
from the bushes behind him
he separates from the group and
investigates the noise
there he sees a light flashing from far
away
it looks like someone is trying to
communicate in morse code
john looks behind to call sherlock but
they have already walked far
john decodes the morse and finds that it
is saying umqra
unsure of what that means he goes back
looking for sherlock and henry
the other two have already reached the
doer's hollow sherlocks goes inside the
pit to check as he looks around he sees
a massive animal on the edge of the pit
henry sees it too
nervous henry comes running to sherlock
asking if he saw it too
the two then get out of the pit and meet
john
henry tells john that they saw the hound
but sherlock insists that he did not
henry is frustrated by sherlock's denial
he is sure that sherlock saw it too and
is happy to find that he did not make
the hound up
later john and sherlock are in a
restaurant sherlock doesn't talk and
looks nervous
as jon tells him about the morse code
sherlock interrupts him to tell him that
he actually saw the hound to
he denied seeing it earlier to hide the
fact that he was scared
john tries calming him suggesting he is
imagining things
sherlock reacts with anger insisting
that he is in a good mental state
the two get into a fight after which
john walks away from him
outside the restaurant he sees the same
morse code blinking far away in the
hills
he sets off to look for the source
finally he finds that they were just
headlights from flashes from a group of
doggers
embarrassed he returns back henry is
back home when he suddenly wakes up at
night suddenly he starts to hallucinate
the night his father was killed he sees
the words liberty and repeatedly
he tries watching tv but every show has
some kind of dog in it
suddenly the outline turns on and off
henry gets his gun out just then there's
a bang on the glass door the lights
start to flicker again
scared he falls to the floor
the following day sherlock makes jon go
on a date with henry's therapist louise
mortimer john tries getting information
out of her without revealing his true
intention
the pair share a flirty drink as they
chat about baskerville and the hound but
dr franklin ruins the mood when he
exposes john as a professional
investigator louise lee's right after
the following morning sherlock goes to
henry's home he is overly excited which
sets henry off he has not slept in days
because of his night terrors sherlock's
directly runs to the kitchen to make
himself a coffee and starts looking
through the cabinets henry asks him why
he denied seeing the hound the other day
but sherlock dismisses it instead he
questions henry why the creature is
called hound
before he can let henry answer sherlock
abruptly leaves the place and sees john
writing something on his notepad
while talking sherlock realizes
something he suggests that the word
hound is actually an acronym that stands
for something
john is confused but goes with his
friend's theory
just then sherlock runs into dialystrod
who he suspects has been sent to
dartmouth by his brother mycroft
meanwhile sean reveals a clue he
discovered earlier inside the end where
he and sherlock are staying is a receipt
for a large delivery of meat even though
the bar and restaurant is strictly
vegetarian the innkeeper admits that he
briefly kept a wild dog on the moor
disguising it as the famous hound to
boost tourism however he insists that
the creature's been put down a month ago
and in any case it bears little
resemblance to the monstrous creature
that sherlock and henry encountered
after that sherlock claims that he has a
theory but has to go to baskerville to
test it they cannot pull the fake card
trick again so sherlock calls his
brother who provides him with access to
baskerville again
he plans to distract the major as soon
as they get inside
then he wants john to check all the labs
for the glowing hound
john is investigating the labs and goes
further in the labs than they did last
time
suddenly a lab light flashes onto his
eyes he hears a ringing noise the light
keeps on shining brighter and the
ringing gets worse
john tries to get out of the place but
his key card stops working
suddenly the lights go off in the
ringing stops the room is pitch dark
john then hears a noise and looks for it
around the lap
he notices a broken cage
some animal might have broken out just
then he hears a growl he runs to the
door again and uses his card but to no
avail the growling starts to get louder
so he locks himself in a cage to save
him from the animal just then sherlock
calls him he frantically tells sherlock
to come and save him
sherlock asks him if he can see the
hound john answers that he does
just then sherlock turns the lights on
and lets john out john tries to explain
to sherlock that he saw the hound but
sherlock dismisses him saying that he
was drugged sherlock then goes to see
another doctor from the lab dr stapleton
he borrows her microscope and studies
the sugar from earlier sherlock suspects
that they have been drugged to see the
product of their imagination that is the
hound he and henry both had tea at
henry's home before they went to the
hollow that day
he believes that the sugar they put into
the tea was drugged because both henry
and he saw the hound but john did not
and john had not taken sugar with his
tea
before coming to baskerville sherlock
has given john coffee with the same
sugar in it hence he hallucinated the
hound in the lab
however as he checks the sugar he can
find no trace of a narcotic agitated he
throws it to the wall
he then uses a mind technique that he
likes to call the mind palace
while meditating he deduces that liberty
and end actually mean liberty indiana
and hound was a project at a cia
facility in liberty indiana
after accessing confidential files
sherlock finally realizes the truth
the project town was established 20
years ago in indiana by a group of five
researchers
they had developed a new drug intended
to be used as a weapon to disorientate
the enemy
however the project was shut down
because of what it did to the subjects
it was tested on it made the subject
extremely violent causing many homicides
the same drug had been given to henry to
make him hallucinate the entire project
was abandoned but someone has started it
up again
as sherlock brainstorms who would do
this he realizes that it is dr franklin
he has been in the field for a long time
moreover sherlock had picked up on his
american dialect dr franklin was in
indiana when project hound was running
his obsession with the drug did not
change after moving to the uk
meanwhile henry is in his therapy
session with louise when suddenly he
fires at her hallucinating that she is
the hound thankfully he misses as he
gets back to his senses he realizes what
he has done he apologizes to the doctor
and runs away taking the gun with him
just then john gets a call from louise
who informs him of henry's outburst
earlier she informs that henry has gone
out with a gun
sherlock deduces that he must have gone
to the doers hollow
when sherlock and john reach there henry
is inside the pit trying to kill himself
sherlock manages to talk him out of it
explaining that the hound was a
hallucination henry's father was killed
not by a devilish hound but by franklin
who was wearing a gas mask with red
colored lenses and a sweater with the
words hound and liberty and on it
henry finally comes back to his senses
but just then the place starts to fog a
huge hound appears on top of the pit
lestrade is there too
the force start to panic when sherlock
suddenly sees dr franklin there
sherlock realizes that the fog was drug
the whole time
they killed a hound and as the fog
clears up henry looks at the hound and
realizes that it is just an ordinary dog
the fog had made them hallucinate
sherlock explains that pressure pads are
installed around the hollow which
released a dose of the chemical compound
dosing henry each time he visited with
henry unstable and delirious his
credibility was damaged meaning his
father's death and the dubious
experiments at baskerville could be
covered up
henry realizes that franklin murdered
his father because his father had found
him continue testing the drug on people
he flies into a vengeful rage and
attempts to throttle franklin but the
doctor escapes after a brief chase
franklin runs into the baskerville
minefield and steps on a mine killing
himself in the explosion
the next day sherlock and john are
having coffee discussing the case
john is confused as to why he saw the
hound in the lab despite not having
inhaled the gas from the moor
sherlock tries to explain that the pipes
in the lab must have been leaking the
gas but john correctly guesses that it
was sherlock who trapped him in the
baskerville lab the terrifying noises
made by the hound were actually just
sound effects played in by sherlock as
he attempted to test his theory that the
hallucinogenic drugs had been planted in
henry's sugar
john also purposely reminds sherlock of
being wrong when he previously deduced
the drug was in the sugar which hits
sherlock's nerves he implies he won't
get it wrong again another time
at the last scene we see sherlock
approaching the innkeeper implying that
the innkeeper lied about having his dog
put down it was indeed his dog that the
drug sherlock and the others had
perceived as the terrifying beast
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching